this is the man who is set to become  president of Africa's most populous  country Muhammadu Buhari first rule  nigeria as a military dictator but he  now calls himself a convert to democracy  who hari had been locked in a tight race  for the presidency against incumbent  Goodluck Jonathan with Jonathan  conceding defeat this will be the first  democratic change of power in the  history of Nigeria Jonathan's five years  in office have been marked by corruption  scandals the country is also facing a  book or Haram insurgency in the  Northeast in the opposition stronghold  of Carnot many say that no matter what  the outcome they're happy the election  has been peaceful this petition is very  high that is the first time we're having  this kind of election because you can  see the mood Tim what is happy at the  first timer silly very stiff competition  as final results came in people in  northern Nigeria spilled onto the  streets to celebrate their country's  historic election